hi everyone i'm beau i run the blyle dev
channel on youtube
and today we're going to be going over
how to create a full stack flutter
application
utilizing firebase authentication and
firebase
firestore along with some open sourced
apis
for this project we're going to have
four key parts that we're going to be
setting up
firebase setup flutter setup to
integrate with firebase
we're going to build our flutter
application and last we're going to hook
up our apis to our application
as well as firestore to our application
by the end of this video you should be
able to hook up apis into your flutter
application and utilize them
you should be able to utilize firebase
authentication in your app
at a more basic level and we should be
able to perform crud operations
using firestore in your flutter
application so those are the main goals
that we're going to focus on today to
accomplish these goals we're going to be
building a
cryptocurrency wallet app we're going to
be able to
add coins and how much of that coin a
user has to the wallet
we're going to be able to read the
current value converted into
u.s dollars of that wallet and we're
going to allow the users to
sell or remove coins from their wallet
and this basic functionality is going to
allow us to practice
using our apis using firestore and using
firebase authentication
i'd like to thank free code camp for
this awesome opportunity make sure to
subscribe to their channel below by
clicking that subscribe button
and if you're interested there'll be a
link to my channel in the description as
well for this project we're going to be
using vs code as our main editor
i'm going to assume that you've probably
already done a flutter application or
two before this video
if you haven't that's okay you can
follow along and build this out as we go
if you're new to flutter development
that's okay be sure to check out
flutter.dev
and then follow their steps for setting
up your machine to use flutter
in this case we're going to be using vs
code and utilizing some of their flutter
extensions
in our project the key one being
awesome flutter flutter
and dart language support the first
thing we need to do is set up
firebase to work with our application
but before we can do that we need to
create a project first so that we can
hook it up to firebase
to do this we're going to open up our
command prompt in vs code and we're
going to select
flutter new project for this project
we're going to call it
crypto wallet
and then i'm just going to place it on
my desktop once your app's finished
building we're going to go over to
firebase
and you're going to go to
firebase.google.com and we're going to
click get started
and all we're going to do is follow the
prompts for creating a new project
so i'm going to call my crypto wallet
i'm going to enable google analytics
select my default analytics account once
it's finished building
you'll get a page like this and we'll
click continue this is your firebase
dashboard this is where we're going to
manage
everything that we're going to be using
with firebase from authentication
to our firestore hookups and to setting
up the connections to our mobile app
the first thing we want to do is we want
to configure firebase to connect to our
flutter application
to do this we're going to click on ios
there's one field that we need to
incorporate in order to hook up our ios
side of our app
to firebase and that's our bundle
identifier
to find your bundle identifier you're
going to go into your flutter
application in xcode
if you're developing on a mac you want
to make sure you open up xcode
we're going to go to our ios folder and
we're going to select the
white icon runner.xc
workspace not work proj
i'm going to open it
i'm going to click on our runner and
under general
you're going to see here we have our
bundle identifier
and we're simply going to copy this
and paste it into google alternatively
another way to find your bundle
identifier is by opening up
the ios folder runner.xcodeproject
project.pbxproj and then you're going to
search for
bundle and you're going to see here
there's a variable called
product bundle identifier and that is
the name of the bundle id that you want
to use
so if you're not using mac or
alternatively you just don't want to
open xcode
you can go to this file and grab the
product bundle identifier and use that
instead
we're going to select register app
we're going to download the config file
i'm just going to drag it to my desktop
next we can skip this step we can skip
this step
as that is specific to swift and we can
skip the verify the next piece we want
to do is we want to make sure we add the
android side to our app
now this is going to be similar but the
package name is going to be slightly
different
so you'll see here they suggest you go
to your app level
android app build.gradle
and right near the top you'll see
under default config and application id
and this is going to be our package name
i'm going to copy that
we're going to paste it here register
that app
download the config file
and unlike the ios side we are going to
follow the instructions listed
in the following extra tasks so the
first one it tells us to do is go to our
project folders
build.gradle file and we are going to
add in the following line
when it means project level it means the
android root folder
and we're simply going to add this right
here in our dependencies under our build
script
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to navigate to our app
build.gradle
and we're going to copy the supply
plug-in line
and paste it right here with the other
apply plug-ins
and then we're going to get under
dependency
we're going to add firebase analytics
because we've got that enabled
there we go everything's set up for
android
skip that step and the last thing we
want to do
is in our project we want to make sure
we add in our new google files that we
downloaded our config files
our one for ios and our one for android
for ios what we're going to do
is you're going to navigate to your
runner folder
the same folder where you find your
info.plist
and that's where we're going to place
our file
quick side note if you're building on
ios and run into an issue where it can't
find the google plist file that we
recently downloaded from firebase
don't worry there's a quick fix to it go
into xcode
right click on runner click add files to
runner
and then you're going to want to select
the google service info p list
that we recently downloaded add it
there you go and now you shouldn't get
this issue anymore the android google
file should be placed right within this
app folder
okay we have two more very simple steps
to follow to finish our firebase setup
the first that we want to do is we want
to set up authentication
for this application we're going to set
up a sign in method of email and
password
and we're just going to check the top
box
and that's it now we can hook up our app
to firebase authentication
the next thing we want to do is we want
to go to cloud firestore
click create database and we're going to
start it in test mode
what test mode is it's going to allow
any read and write abilities
to this database but it's going to place
a time stamp on it
we're going to use this for our testing
and once we're ready to deploy into
production
we're going to change it to production
mode and modify the rules
next we're going to select a region
since i'm on the east coast of the us
but i anticipate a lot of west coast
users as that's where a lot of family
and friends are
i'm going to keep it on uscentral and
there we have it we've officially set up
our firebase console
to manage our flutter application the
next thing we're going to do is i'm
going to quickly clean up
the flutter application in our main.dart
file
i'm going to remove the theme.date the
theme data
i'm going to simplify this class below
the homepage class remove a title from
its implementation
and then i'm going to clear out most of
the contents
of the clear state class i'm going to
clear out everything within scaffold
and only have a body of type container
remove this title okay
and i'm going to remove this unused
method okay i'm officially ready to
start my flutter application but the
first thing we're going to do
is we're going to install the packages
necessary to talk with firebase
from our flutter application so let's go
ahead and do that next
the first thing we need to do is we need
to go to our pubspec.yaml file
and underneath of dependencies
this is where we're going to put our
flutter fire dependencies the first
dependency we want to add
is authentication
so we're just going to copy straight
from the firebase.flutter.dev
documentation
and we're going to paste it into our app
and this will give us the most recent
version available on firefighter
next up we're going to go down to cloud
firestore and do the same thing
except we don't need to copy in firebase
core as we already did that with
authentication
okay upon saving vs code
should run pubget if not you need to
open up your terminal
and run flutter pub get that way it
imports it into your application
and that's it that was the most
difficult part about connecting with
firebase everything from here on out is
going to be a breeze
so with that let's go ahead and build
out our flutter application the first
thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to shell out all the files
that i know i'm going to need in
anticipation of having to create them
anyways so let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to create a couple folders
one called model one that i'm going to
call net
and the other that i'm going to call ui
and i'm going to go ahead
and create a file called authentication
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to have a single file that handles
our authentication there'll be two
fields there'll be an
email field a password field and we'll
have both a login and
register button so regardless of what
the user is intending to do whether
sign up or sign in they can do it all
from that same page
the next two files i know i'm going to
need are my flutter fire functions file
and my api functions file so i'm going
to go ahead and create those in my net
folder
and lastly i'm going to have one model
class at least
which is going to contain my coin
class
for the time being we're only going to
mess with our authentication file and
we'll come back to these other ones
later on
we're going to first import material
[Applause]
and then we're going to create a
stateful widget
and that's going to be called
authentication
with a capital
a
it's important to note that file names
are always lowercase letters with
underscores in between words
and your classes are always uppercase
camel case so the first letter in each
new word is uppercase
and the rest are lower i'm then going to
add just a simple container
and i'm going to make the container
a material okay the next thing i'm going
to do is i'm actually going to delete
the class from the main file
i should have just done that to begin
with and instead of my home page being
the file that we're going to return
we're going to return authentication
one more thing that we want to make sure
that we incorporate into our application
is instantializing our firebase hookup
so right at the very start we're going
to call await
firebase.initialize app and we're going
to do this right inside
our main
we're going to then import firebase core
make this main method asynchronous and
we're off to the races
so we're first going to focus all on the
ui of our authentication page
so let's go ahead and do that the first
thing we want to do is we want to give
our container a width of media query
dot size dot width
and we're going to give it a height
of media queried out of context not size
to height what this will do is it'll
expand the container to fill
the screen's max width and max height so
it'll fill
the entire screen we're then going to
add a decoration
of type box decoration
and this is going to allow us to modify
the colors
if you want to add bordering to any
containers if you want to add
any additional styling you'll always use
a decoration to do this
so i'm going to say colors dot
let's do a blue accent for now
add a comma for some there we go
and we're going to add a child of type
text
that's just going to say hello world
the last thing we're going to do before
we start up this app is we are going to
add
widgetsflutterbinding.ensure initialize
this is a method we need to add if we're
going to initialize the application in
our main
method now that all the setup is done
we're going to go back to our
authentication file
and we're going to get to work on our
authentication page
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to make this a scaffold that
it's going to be returning
which takes a type body so we had it as
material that was the default that the
class builder object created but we want
it to be of type scaffold for this root
container and then instead of hello
world
we are going to have a column and the
reason for this
is we want to display two fields an
email form field
a password form field and then we want
to have two buttons and they're all
vertical so there's nothing to the left
or right it's just
up and down and so a column is going to
allow us to place all of those
vertically positioned from each other so
the first one we have
is a text form field
and this is going to be for our email
we're going to have another text form
field
for our password we are going to have a
let's just do it inside of a container
for our buttons okay and we're going to
start filling these out
so what we need to do is since we're
doing a text form field we need to have
a controller
that can capture the input that the user
puts into the form
so to do this we need a text editing
controller
and we're going to call this one email
field
and it's going to be equal to a text
editing
controller and then we're going to
repeat the same thing for password
we're just going to call it password
instead of email field
so password field and these are going to
be the values that we're going to pass
to our method when the user clicks
login or register the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to add these
controllers to our text form fields that
we just created
so for the top one it's the email
controller
and for the bottom one it's the password
the next thing we want to do is we want
to make sure the user feels secure when
they're entering their password so we
don't want to just show the password for
anyone to see
we just want them to be able to see it
one letter at a time
and so what we're going to do for that
is there's a method here called obscure
text it's a it's a property on text form
field
and it takes in a boolean input so by
simply saying true
what will happen is when the user's
typing in it'll block out all the
previously typed characters
so that's the kind of action that we
want to have and then the last thing we
want to do is we want to give these
a decoration so i believe text input
decoration
no input decorate that's the one input
decoration
and you can see even i struggle with
this having done it hundreds of times
don't feel bad if you have to google
something or if you have to mess around
with it a little bit
in order to find the field that you're
really looking for so for input
decoration this is going to allow us to
change things such as the hint
or the label associated with the feel
styling
for the input input
text form field um it's gonna allow us
to manipulate all of these different
things
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
put a hint text and it'll be
something uh let's just say email.com
the next thing that we want to change is
we want to add a label
for label text we'll just call it email
and for label style it takes in
a text style input and we're going to
say colors
dot white okay
and we're going to do the same thing for
hint style we're going to say text style
color it's colors dot white
okay and by putting a trailing comma
like this
the dart formatter will format our code
for us
and i think that's all we want to do for
this one so what we're going to do is
we're going to actually copy this
decoration
we're going to come down to password
and we're going to paste it and we're
just going to replace the label
to say password and for this one
we're just going to say password for the
hint
and kind of going back up to the top
really quick
we've got a background of this light
blue we can keep it at that we've made
the form fields have a white text
so just be aware of the colors you're
using we're not going to style this a
ton
again we're just trying to get some
basic functionalities that we can get
into the real nitty-gritty of the api
methods and working with firestore
but this will serve our purpose for now
in our containers
we need to give them first a decoration
and we're gonna give them a box
decoration
and the reason why we wanted to give
them a box decoration
is i want to create some white buttons
with rounded borders
and to do that using a box decoration we
can easily say
border radius dot circular
and give them a nice
rounded border okay
and then we can say color is equal to
colors
dot white the last thing we need to do
is we need to give it a width which we
can say
media query
dot of context dot size dot width
divided by 1.4
and again what media query does is it
gives us the width of the screen
and it allows us to basically say okay
no matter what kind of device you're
using i want to
give back a width based on the size of
that device
so it'll be unique to each device and
this way it'll format nicely no matter
what device it's being used on
whether it's an ipad or an iphone or a
google pixel
no matter what kind of device it is
it'll format it nicely
and then we want to just give it a
height
of let's just say 40. uh 45
let's do 45 and then it's going to have
a
child of material button
which will have an on press method which
for now
we're going to leave blank and the
material button will have a child of
type text
which will say register we'll put
register on top
and we are going to actually just copy
this container
and use it for in
and all we need to do is change this to
login
and we're good to go going back to our
main let's click run
open up my simulator here so you guys
can see we're going to wait for it to
build
okay once that's built you should get
something similar to this screen
now the formatting of this is really
ugly but you have seen that the padding
on the sides of the buttons is about
what we wanted so to resolve the issue
of everything being pushed right at the
top
we're going to go to our column and
we're going to say
main axis alignment dot
space between actually let's do space
evenly
and again we don't care too much about
um
how things look we're going more for
functionality so putting space between
it allows for space evenly it puts an
equal amount of spacing
and padding between each item so we've
got email
password register button login button
okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to test this out
there we go okay those are working as
expected and we are going to go ahead
and check okay buttons or function is
functioning as expected the next thing
we need to do is we need to create our
authentication methods
to sign a user in and sign user up so
we're going to go
over to our firebase file so our flutter
fire
and we're going to create two methods
the first one is going to be a future
type of
void and it's going to be called sign in
and that's going to take a string of
email and a string
a password
and the second one is going to be
similar
it's going to be called register
so what we're going to do for our
register method is we're going to do a
try catch
and for the catch i'm actually going to
just paste in
this exception handling for firebase
so you'll see here firebase auth
exception quick fix
import that okay to put a space between
these methods for clarity
in this try statement we're going to say
our wait
firebase auth dot instance
dot create user with email and password
to which we're gonna pass in
our email oh my goodness
and we're gonna pass in our password
here
okay so let's go over what's going on
right here
so we're going to create an instance of
firebase authentication
and this has a bunch of different
methods that we can access
and we can utilize such as signing the
user in
verifying email there's a lot of
different methods associated with
firebase authentication the one we are
interested in however
is creating a user with an email and
password as that
is the method that we set up on firebase
and all we have to do is pass an email
password if it's successful
things will go on it'll complete and we
can enter the application just fine
if however it throws an error then we
know we don't want to route the user
and it'll throw one of these exceptions
right here it'll just print it to the
console
so what we're going to do is we're
actually going to change this to a type
of string response actually let's change
it to a bool
and what we'll do is if it's successful
we can return true and if it's
unsuccessful
we'll just return false so we'll just
say
return false and we'll say
return false after it prints out those
logs
now ideally we'll we would handle these
exceptions and display the validation
error that's occurring
and in an even more ideal situation you
would probably use the provider package
or some other kind of state management
to set up your authentication in a very
smooth
clean way if you were to publish this
app this will work for our purposes it's
totally fine nothing's going to break
it'll serve our purpose so we're going
to continue with this and the way that
this is going to work
is we are simply going to say when the
user
registers so that's this one
let me put a comma after here for some
formatting clarity
we are going to make this an
asynchronous
method and we are going to say
should navigate it's equal to await
register and we're going to pass to it
our email field dot text
and our password field dot text
and it's probably going to prompt us to
import that one file
okay and then what we're going to say is
we're going to say
if should navigate
navigate which we'll get to here in a
minute else actually we don't even need
an else
um for for now nothing will happen if
you press it we'll just say nothing
happens
and we're going to just copy this
because we're going to be doing
something similar
with our login so in login we're going
to do the same thing
except it will be sign in
and this will be asynchronous as well
and going back to our flutter file file
we're going to change this to a type of
boolean for sign in
and there we go that's resolved now we
still need to build out the sign in
method so let's go ahead and do that
again we're going to do a try catch
statement and in this one i'm just going
to put catch
e for error and we're going to say print
e
return false if it's unsuccessful
and we're going to try to do a wait
firebase auth instance
in with email and password
and then we have our email
and we have our password if
this feels like i'm going too fast feel
free to pause
slow down or even check out the code i
always put this code public
on my github page and so if you'd like
to check that out as well so you can
follow along better
by all means please do that
and it's still upset here because we
haven't put a return statement for
inside the try
so if it successfully hits this line
that means no error was thrown when it
signed the user up
therefore we can return true and let the
authentication page know
hey you're good to go now that we've
shelled out our authentication page
let's create one more new view that
we're going to use after authentication
which we're just going to call home view
and i'm going to make this a
stateful widget called home view
for child i'll just do a text with
home view
as that text we're going to need to
import material
there we go
going to close that out i'm going to
remove these files that we're not using
and we're going to focus purely on the
authentication routing
to the home view so what we're going to
do is we're going to say navigator
dot push and this is going to take two
parameters
one of context and the other of material
page route
material page route has a builder method
we're going to be using
i'm going to say context and then we're
going to say
home view that is where we want to go
okay
add in home view let's add on some
trailing commas here
for formatting sake
okay and i'm going to copy this
navigator.push method
i'm going to place it under register as
well so if we successfully registered
the user or log them
in we should push and display
our new page that we want to go to and
what home view is going to be
is it's going to be where we contain all
of our methods for
adding coins removing coins and viewing
the current
value of our coins going to start it up
so we can see if it's working and we can
test with firebase
so let's go ahead and see if this works
and if we have time we'll come
back to this and we will make it a
little bit better a little bit cleaner
looking
so i'm going to type in an email i'm
going to give it a very simple password
i'm going to say register and we've
successfully gone into our home view
now you may be wondering why is it a
black screen with
these double underlines and the reason
for that
is we currently are returning a type of
container
what we want to do is make this of type
material
i'm going to hot reload that page and
now you'll see that we have a white
background like we're expecting
and the home view in the top left corner
and
actually what we're going to do is we're
going to make this instead of material
widget let's make it a scaffold widget
and the reason for this is we want to
use a floating action button
to show the add button and scaffold has
a nice
built-in property for
floating action buttons we're going to
do that instead and in place of the body
we're going to place a container
let's give the container a width of
media query
dot of context dot
size that size.width we want it to fill
the space of the entire screen
and for height we are going to do the
same but instead of width
i'm going to say dot height
and let's go ahead and give it a
decoration
box decoration and let's do color
colors dot white and then
for child we can do our text
hello world
so before we go ahead and create the add
and remove methods to connect to
firestore
let's go ahead and show out the ui for
our home view
so in place of this text widget what
we're instead going to do is we're going
to create
a stream builder widget
and stream builders have two parts the
stream and what you want to do with the
data that you get from the stream
so to set up the stream we're going to
say stream and then we're going to say
firebase firestore
dot instance dot collection
and what we're doing right now is we're
creating a path
to the specific collection that we want
to be listening to and watching
and so we're creating a path to that and
setting it as our stream
users.doc the name of the document that
we want to reference
is firebaseauth.instance.currentuser.uid
and then it's going to be a collection
under that user called coins
and then we say dot snapshots
okay scrolling back to the left
okay so this is the stream that we have
set up we're basically going to tell the
user to be
or tell the stream builder to be looking
at
the user dock of the currently
authenticated user
and then to check out any documents
under the collection
coins and that's where we're going to be
storing all the coins that the user has
and so what we're trying to do with the
stream builder is display a list
of all the different coins that the user
has and the most recent pricing
and value of the coins that that user
has
and so the next part that we're going to
do
is we're going to add our builder aspect
and the builder
is going to have a couple of variables
it's going to have a build context
of context and we're going to have an
asynchronous snapshot
of type query snapshot
called snapshot
okay and let's see did i spell this
right
async snapshot
oh i missed an s that's why it was not
working for me
it's a little confused there for a
minute okay so these are the two
arguments that it's taking
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say if
not snapshot.hasdata
return centered
a circular progress indicator
so what this will do is in the case that
let me put comma here for formatting in
the case that
it is still trying to read in the data
or it's been unable to process it quite
yet
it hasn't quite gotten the data it is
going to return
a circular progress indicator which will
just keep on spinning until it gets data
then what we're going to do is outside
of this if statement we're going to have
a list view that we're going to render
that displays all the data because if
we've passed
over this if statement we know that the
snapshot
does have data so then we can do
something with it so we're going to say
return list view
and the list view is going to have
children
of type snapshots
dot data dot
docs dot
map and we're going to map those to a
variable called document
okay
we're almost there and after it
we want to say dot to list so we're
going to list them out
okay yes and then what we're going to do
is inside of here
we're going to say return container
and the container is going to have
let's say a row element or a row widget
and it's gonna have two children we're
gonna have
um coin
we'll call it coin name
and then for the second one
we'll call it um
amount owned
and this may all seem a little confusing
at first but here in a second it's all
going to come together and make sense
and we're going to give this row a main
axis alignment
of let's do space evenly
okay so let's discuss what's going on
here
so we've already talked about how if we
passed over this if statement that means
we have data
so what we're doing is with that data we
are taking that data
and what it is is it's a list of
documents found in firestore
so what we're going to do is we're going
to map them out and we're basically
going to have this list view
iterate through each document and with
each document
we're going to create and return a
container and what we're going to do
here
is we're going to display right here
we'll do it right now so we can see this
so we're going to do some string
interpolation here and we're going to
say
document dot id
and the reason i'm saying this is
because we're going to store the name
of the coin in the id of the document
so if you remember us talking about this
we're going to limit how many types of
coins the user can actually utilize
and so because of this we're just going
to store
the name of the the name of the coin
that the user has
as the identifying value of the document
and then what we're going to do here
this is going to be a little bit more
complex because what we have to do under
amount owned
is we need to take the so there's a
value that we're going to be storing
it'll be document.data
and then it's going to be called amount
but that's not the only value that we
need to display here
we need to multiply this by the current
price
of the coin on the market and so we're
going to have to
create we'll probably do it in the
on inits state class
on a net state method in this class
but we're gonna have to fetch the
current price of each coin
and then what we'll do here is we'll
basically say okay take the amount of
that coin they have so let's say they
have
one tether coin and let's say tether is
worth
five dollars i believe it's worth one
but for this example we'll say five
we don't wanna display one here we wanna
display five dollars because that's how
much that user owns of tether
so what we're gonna need to do is we're
gonna need to have some business logic
and a fun activity if you feel like this
isn't complex enough for you or you want
to take it a step further
rework this whole project but utilize
block
provider river pods utilize some other
kind of state management process
so that you can perform the business
logic in a much cleaner fashion
we're going to do it here but it's going
to be pretty rudimentary just so we can
show
how to access apis how to interact with
firestore that's our main focus but if
you want to challenge yourself and take
this a step further
try to implement some state management a
more effective cleaner solution estate
management
into your example that's not the focus
of this video however so we're gonna
go past that so this is the general idea
for now i'm going to keep it
as this remember we said we're going to
work out the ui first and then we'll
come back to hooking everything up to
firestore
into the api so let's leave it like that
for now
and the next thing we need to do is
let's find our scaffold
let's see here here's our scaffold
so we want to add a floating action
button and what the floating action
button is going to be
is it's going to route us to a new page
where the user can add in new coins
and the floating action button is going
to basically
be our clean simple way of the user
adding additional coins to
the list and the reason why going back
to the stream builder that we want to
utilize the stream builder
is that when we do an action like adding
in
a new value the stream builder will pick
up the changes live from firestore and
immediately render them
in the view so we don't have to
constantly be checking hey do you have
more data hey do you have more data hey
do you have more data
the stream's just going to say hey i
noticed a change in firestore
let's update the ui so that's why we're
doing a stream builder here
okay for the floating action button
we're gonna have two bits we're gonna
have
so let's create the floating action
button
we need to have an on press method which
is where we're gonna route
to that new file which we're gonna call
add view
and that's going to have our um
our drop down with the different options
of coins you can add
and a form field where they can add in
the
number of coins that they want to add in
and then we'll have a submit button
so that's what's going to go in the
unpressed and so let's actually work
that out right now
but we're going to say navigator dot
push
and it's going to take in a context and
material
page route and material page route has a
builder
that has a context which then calls
our ad view unfortunately though we have
not
yet created the ad view
class so it may not like this
so what we need to do is we need to go
here to our ad view and we need to say
stateful widget and we're going to call
it add view
and for now it's just going to display a
text
add view we will come back to this next
and we will be modifying this and i'm
going to replace that container with a
material widget
okay going back to our home view it's no
longer getting upset about that
so our on pressed is good to go so now
all we have to do is customize what is
within
the floating action button that the user
sees in our case we want just a simple
plus button
that's kind of the uniform add button so
we're going to go ahead and say child is
equal to icon
we can say icons dot add
color of the icon will be white
and let's give it a background color
of blue
okay i believe that's all we want to do
there
okay so this is all looking good
we haven't quite hooked up our api
method yet remember we're working out
the ui first and then we'll go to that
let's go over to our ad view and let's
just shell out this ad view really
quickly
so what we're going to do with in the ad
view is there's a couple of
state variables that we need to
establish we need to establish the list
of different
options that the user can select from
and we need to create a string variable
that's going to be equal to the value
that the user has selected
in addition to that we're going to need
a text editing controller
to be listening to and to capture the
text input that the user puts for their
number
so what we're going to do here is in
place of this text we're going to have a
column
okay that's our base widget that we're
working with
and we're going to have three elements
we're going to have our drop down button
our container
um that is our input container and then
we're gonna have a button
and the button's really easy because
we've already created a clean button on
our authentication page
for login so we'll probably just copy
that button over and save us a lot of
time
but let's go ahead and work on the drop
down button first
the first thing we need to do before we
can create that widget is we need to
create
the list of strings
that we want to display so i'm going to
call this coins
and i'm going to set it equal to
a list of three coins we're going to
have bitcoin
we're going to have tether and let's
have
uh ethereum there we go
so these are our coins we're then gonna
have
a drop down value that's equal to
bitcoin we're just to default it to
bitcoin
first one in the list now let's go down
oh let's do one more thing i'm sorry
text editing controller we'll call this
a mount controller
this equal to text editing controller
just default it to that
okay now we can add in our drop down
button so let's go
drop down button
and the drop down button has a couple of
elements we have our value which is
going to be set to our drop down value
and what this will do is whenever the
user selects a new value in the drop
down
it will set well we are going to set
the value of this drop-down value
variable
to the newest selected value which will
in turn update
the displayed value on that drop-down
okay the next thing we need to do is we
need to have our orange change method
so unchanged has a value
oops so what we want to do here is we
want to say
her let's actually let's specify it's a
string
what we want to do here is we want to
basically just do a set state
so we say set state and we want to set
drop down value is equal to
value and like we just mentioned we're
going to
replace the value of drop down value
with the recently selected one
and that'll in turn update our drop down
button
that's our unchanged now the only thing
left is our items field
so we've already listed out our items
you see here it's expecting a list of
drop down menu items
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to do coins which is the name
of the list of different available coins
that we provided
then we're going to say dot map and
we're going to say
drop down menu
item and it's drop down menu item
of type string so we're going to add on
that
close the bracket then we're going to
have a method in here
that has an input of type string value
okay we've got to be very careful with
our commas
and our closing brackets and make sure
everything's working well
okay and then what we're going to do
and this isn't oh that needs to be a
lowercase
okay then what we're going to do in here
is we're going to say return
drop-down menu item
type string and it's gonna have two
variables we have
our value
and we have our child
which we're just gonna keep it simple
and just do text
and display value for that text
and close that with a semicolon
i believe that's it we're going to test
it here in a bit
and see for sure if we got that right
but
so what we're doing is we're mapping out
the different values in our list
for each value we're creating a drop
down menu item
and the drop down menu item we can
customize it however we want but in our
case we're just going to keep it
a simple text that displays the value
that we're looking at
so it'll say bitcoin tether and ethereum
just a simple list
with text fields or not fields they're
just
text text widgets
okay so that's all i want for the drop
down button
the next thing is pretty simple we've
done it already before we're going to do
a text
form field now we're going to constrain
this one to a container
that way we can if you remember
when we did our first one on our
authentication page
we haven't put any padding on it yet and
so it goes
edge to edge and it looks a little funky
so we're going to
change that for this one and we're going
to give it a width
and we're going to say media query dot
of
context dot size dot width divided by
1.3
and then we're going to give a child
text form field
in that text form field we have our
controller already set up
which is a mount controller perfect
we're going to give it a decoration
of type input decoration
and the reason for that is that we can
give it a label
and the label is going to say um
how much of this coin
let's keep it simple coin mount
and i won't mess with the styling we'll
just keep it simple on this one if you'd
like to spruce up yourself
have at it be a great practice in
working on your styling skills and your
widget formatting skills okay
and i think that's all we want to do
be really simple maybe we'll add a
keyboard
text input type dot
number with options
hmm let's do actually i'm going to keep
it text
i can't remember if number allows you to
do
decimals or not i think it might
restrict it kind of like a phone number
so we're going to just keep it as
and actually let's just remove that
entirely we don't really care for that
right now
maybe we'll go back and style that a
little bit more later and as i mentioned
in our authentication page we've already
created a button
so let's take this material button here
whoa okay
oops too much
there we go copy that
exit out of that close that guy paste
instead of register we're going to say
add
and in this
this is where we're going to call our
firestore method for adding
but we haven't set that up yet so we're
not gonna
worry about that quite yet okay so we've
got our three fields our drop down
our coin amount and our button for
adding
and after this we need to say
navigator.ofcontext.pop
and what that'll do is it'll remove
this material widget from the screen
and bring us back to the original screen
that we were on which is home view
okay i'm going to start this up and
let's check it out
okay so it's built and let's go ahead
and log in
and we're going to come back to this i
don't like the styling whatsoever
too spaced out not enough padding this
text the black when everything else is
white it's a little funky so we're going
to come back to this
as soon as we finish testing and getting
this right and clean this up just a
little bit
log in okay this looks good there's
nothing to display so i'm not very
surprised
we'll have to check it out once we're
starting working with data and maybe
we'll have to modify it a little bit and
clean it up but for now this is great
we've got our floating action button
let's see if it navigates us
okay and we're throwing an error type
maps list iterable
is not a subtype of type list
okay so that'd be here in our ad
view and i'm assuming it's this method
right here
ah we are missing
dot two list let's go get ahead and give
this a hard restart
log in one more time and let's see if it
works this time around
perfect okay and i'm just realizing we
can't see the drop down menu because
it's
it's hidden behind this so let's go up
and for a column let's give it a main
access alignment
of center give it a quick restart
don't need to restart the whole app okay
this is looking good this is how we want
it to look
okay if i pull open the keyboard in the
emulator
this will work um maybe we'll tinker
with
the other keyboard types later and we
got add and add for now just pops you
nothing more
okay so that's good i'm going to close
that down
and let's go back really quick to our
authentication page
and let's clean this up like i was
mentioning earlier there's a couple
things i didn't like
so the first thing to do is the white we
want to make
it white not black
so i believe that all we need to do is
this
[Applause]
done okay first thing that was bugging
me
care of the next thing that was bugging
me is
the fact that these text form fields
went end to end i want to put some
constraints so that they're
less so what we're going to do is we're
going to just cut them
we're going to place them inside of a
container widget
and we're going to give that container
widget a width of media query
contacts dot size
dot width divided by 1.3
and we're going to do the same thing for
the first one
we are going to say child
let's take the widget's width from that
one
and paste it into this one let's
change this to center instead of space
between
and then let's just put some size boxes
for now
[Music]
let's do media query of
context size dot height
divided by 35.
that should be good just like a nice
decent padding nothing too crazy
put them between all of our objects so
they aren't smushed on top of each other
and
[Music]
i think we're good okay we're going to
give this another run
and let's see how those improvements
look
okay this is looking substantially
cleaner than what we originally had
so let's go ahead just do this one more
time
yep that looks great
[Applause]
i'm gonna remove this keyboard for my
own sake log
in everything is looking good
okay let's close this down and let's
shift over to our api methods and our
flutter fire methods so we're going to
start with our flutter fire methods
first
and we're going to be doing something
interesting with our add method
so we're not necessarily just
creating a new document we're
potentially
updating at the same time so we need to
know
what is the current value of that's
inside of that document
and we want to potentially add on to
that value if it exists
so the way that we can do this with
firestore is something called
transactions
so what we're going to do is we're going
to run a transaction and essentially
we're going to be opening up a document
in firestore we're going to be reading
the current value if it exists
and then we're going to be adding on to
that value
and this way we can easily increment the
number of coins that a user has so let's
say
i add one bitcoin today i come back
tomorrow
and i add .02 of a bitcoin
now i don't want to replace the document
with .02
i want to add on to the existing one so
that the document reads 1.02
the transaction is going to help us do
this so what we're first going to do is
we're going to create a future method
and i'm just going to make it a boolean
and we're going to say
add coin and the reason for it being a
boolean is this is just a simple way
of telling the client hey um it worked
or it didn't work
so we're going to turn true if it did
false if it didn't
because we're not necessarily needing
any data on the front end from it
all we want to know is was it successful
in adding or not
so we need two variables that we're
going to be using for this ag coin
i thought about it at first and thought
about utilizing a coin
class but it's really not
real it's
i thought about using a coin class at
first but it kind of felt like we were
pushing it a little bit
when all we really needed were a couple
of simple variables
so what we're first going to do is we
have string id and this is going to be
the id of the document that we're going
to be referencing
and in the case that the document
doesn't exist this will be the name of
the new document that we're creating
and then we're going to have another
value called amount which is also going
to be of type string
the user when they input that number
it's going to be a
text string we're not going to bother on
the front end worrying about formatting
into a nice
double we're going to handle that here
in this method instead
so we're passing it in as a string and
of course because this is a future
method
and we are working with firebase there
is going to need to be
an asynchronicity to this method
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to do a try catch statement
and if we
fail if the try isn't successful and it
catches an exception
we're going to return false because it
was unsuccessful in adding to the
database
and then what we're going to do is
inside the try we're going to say string
uid
because we first need to access the
document of the user before we can even
think
about accessing the documents for the
coins
so we say string uid is equal to
firebaseauth.instance.currentuser.edu
this will give us the uid of the current
authenticated user
we're then going to say var value is
equal to double
dot parse amount so we're we're taking
our string and converting it into a
double
and if we have more time this is another
thing that you can do in your free time
you can add some validation to ensure
that the string that's coming in
is of a type double or simply we can add
some validation logic to the front end
on the add button
to where we don't allow them to add
until they format
their number correctly
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to say document reference
and what this is going to be
is we're going to set this equal to the
reference of the document that we want
to update so it's going to it's going to
basically
be collection user document
users uid collection coins
document the coin id and that is going
to be the path
that we're giving this document
reference object so we're going to say
firebase firestore
dot instance dot collection
users
sorry about that action.users.uid
dot collection points
dot dot id
okay so that is our
document reference and the reason we
need to grab that is this is the crucial
part of the transaction method that
we're going to be using
so now we're going to say firebase
firestore
dot instance dot run
transaction and it's going to be
instead of this okay
it's going to be a method and it needs
to be asynchronous
okay and we're going to say document
snapshot we're going to call it snapshot
is equal to a weight transaction
which is the value that run transaction
produced for us
transaction dot get and then we want to
pass in
our document reference okay
okay making good progress here
so now that we have our snapshot it's
essentially
a capture of the data within that
document we can say
if snapshot.exists
so this means if there's not any data
like not necessarily not any data but
oh not exits exists um
essentially what this means is this
document does not exist already like we
the user has not created a document for
this coin yet
so let's say we're adding bitcoin and
the user's never had bitcoin in their
profile
it'll hit this clause okay so what we
want to do here is we want to
set a new document because um
just because it didn't exist doesn't
mean we don't want it to exist we want
it to exist with our new value
we just don't want to there's no
other logic that needs to be put into
play it's not like we're adding an old
value as well
so we're going to say document reference
dot set
and in here we can set amount
equal to and we called it value
and then we can return false
actually we can return true i'm sorry
about that don't know what i'm thinking
then we can say double new amount
so if the document already exists
we want to first create the new value
that we're going to update the document
with
so we want to say snapshot
dot data and then we want to take
the amount
from that data and just for sake
of consistency i'm going to replace that
with singles
single quotes plus
value and then
we are going to say transaction
dot update and this is important we want
to make sure we say
update and we list what do we want to
update what document
passenger document reference which we
establish here
so we want to update this document
and then we want to say what is what is
it that we want to update within that
document
we want to update a mount and we want
the value
to equal new amount
and we can say return true
okay and before we do a semicolon close
on this run transaction
we can just say actually
we can leave it at that you could do a
then clause to basically say
successfully updated but we don't care
we're returning true and letting the
user know hey all is good in the world
okay so that is adding
so let's go ahead and hook this up to
our ad view
so right here we want to say await and
what did we call this method
we called it add coin
add coin
and add coin takes in two variables the
first one is going to be
drop down value and the second one
is going to be our amount controller
and we need to import our flutter file
file
okay that's looking good now let's go
ahead and give this another run
and see if our stream builder displays
the coin once we've added it and also
make sure that it's actually even adding
the coin in the first place
okay let's go ahead and log in
okay we currently have nothing we can
confirm that
go to add let's add
ethereum let's do that let's say we're
going to add 1.2 of ethereum
we've added it okay
now i'm a little concerned because i'm
not seeing anything
show here
okay so you can see here that it is this
it is
inserting um the coin
into the database but as we saw
here nothing is showing so what we're
going to do is we're going to run one
more test
let's add one bitcoin add it
okay and let's go ahead and close this
down
run it again and while we're waiting for
this to pull up
let's go ahead and check out our home
view and see maybe if we can find out
what we are missing
document.id document.data amount
we're returning to lists there's no
errors we're
mapping the data there's no circular
progress indicator so we know that we
are getting something some kind of
response
let's check out add view really quick
and let's see what or not add view
let's check out our
flutter fire there we go here's our
issue
so the problem is is that we gave a bad
reference we were saying lowercase users
but on our home view we were looking at
the collection with an uppercase u
so firebase is case sensitive so this is
a very
common thing that can happen so you want
to always be sure that you're
using consistency among titles i always
do
uppercase camel case with all my
collections
and that way i just remember it's always
uppercasecamelcase don't even have to
think about it
so what we're going to do here we're
going to restart it i'm going to go
ahead to firebase
and let's go ahead and sure enough you
can see here
users is lowercase i'm going to delete
this collection
just to reset my data okay
and let's go ahead and check out
this again see if we got it right this
time
log in let's add one bitcoin
awesome bitcoin one
let's add in point zero zero zero three
of bitcoin add
awesome now i do wanna cap it i don't
want it to be so long
i want to cap it at say
two decimal places because i think what
we'll do is we'll say
well what we're going to do is we're
going to represent this as
a price so we're going to say
this times whatever the current price is
and so we will have to cap this the
decimal places that's one thing we need
to keep in mind
but so far it's looking good let's do
another one let's do tether as well
say 54 tether okay awesome and you can
see here it's starting to create a list
so the next thing we're going to do is
let's hook up to our api
let's get that live pricing added in
and then we can do a little bit more
styling here
and we'll be off to the races so let's
go ahead and close this down
okay so here's the api that we're going
to be working with it's coingeco.com
they have a free
open to the public api that you can
utilize
unless you're using this for commercial
purposes and really pinging it a lot
it should be perfectly fine to use so
for our case where we're gonna have a
low amount of users
um we're not expecting a ton of people
this is gonna be just fine
so we have this get request um it takes
in an
id of a coin the way that coingecko does
their ids i've already
looked into this a little bit it's the
name of the coin
so we have bitcoin tether ethereum so
the id that we have in our documents we
can utilize that
for this api call as well hence why we
stuck
with the lowercase coin name for the id
and everything it just it flows well
working with the api
so what we're going to do here is let's
go ahead
and test it out so let's click try it
out
we're going to pass bitcoin
click execute
awesome and you can see here here's the
data we're getting back
now the only data we really care about
is
the price so let's look down
let's see here this is description in
different languages
okay here we go okay this is what we
care about
market data then within market data
there's a field called current price
then within current price there's a
field usd
for us dollars so this
is what we care about with this api and
this is what we're going to try to
capture
so let's go back up to the top we're
going to grab
this request url i'm going to
copy that i'm going to
place it right here and the next thing
that we're going to do
is we need to import the http library
in order to do that i believe i've
already done this on this project
but we're going to go to our
pubspec.yaml file yep
and you are going to add in http under
dependencies just place it right with
your other
flutter fire dependencies um or
just under and then you're going to use
the latest version which
as of date of this video it's 12.2
okay um
yes okay so
we've now got that let's import
http and we're gonna say
as http and then we're going to say
future double and
we need to import one more thing oh
thinking
yeah there it is the convert library
okay future double i'll call it get
price
and it takes in an id
okay so we're returning a double
which is the price that the user is
asking for
okay so the way that this works is we're
going to do a try catch
cover our bases here if we
catch an error we're just going to print
the error console
and we're going to return
zero and so if you see
that the current value of a coin is zero
then you know that
you probably did something wrong um
okay
and we're just going to print the error
to the console if we catch an error
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to say var url is equal to
and let's go ahead and copy this url
paste it and the reason i'm leaving off
the ending
is we're going to add on id to the url
okay the next thing we want to do
is we want to say var response
is equal to http dot get
url and what this will do is it will
perform a get request
as if we were working at a postman or
putting this url
api into the browser it's essentially
doing that and it's setting the response
of that object
to this variable called response
we're then going to have a variable
called json which we're going to say
json to code and
it's going to say response dot body
so what we're doing is with the okay why
doesn't it like this
response to body hmm
ah that was incomplete that's why
okay so what we're doing with this is
we're saying
take your response object and with your
response object
i want to take the body element and i
want to format it
in json format and what we can do with
this is we can then say
value is equal to json
and i believe it was called market data
let's confirm
yep market data
oh not dot i want to do another one of
these
it's called current price
current price
usd
and let's just for consistency's sake
we don't want to trust the api to make
the correct decision with formatting so
we can trust ourselves so we're going to
format it as a string
and then we're going to say return
double dot parse of value
and the reason i say that is i've seen
apis before that are poorly managed and
kept
and sometimes they'll return a double
sometimes return to string
sometimes they'll turn in int and it can
cause a lot of problems if you're not
ready for that so i find it best just to
take matters in my own hand
make sure we have a uniform string that
we're reading and then
do with the string as we want afterwards
so what this will do is this will return
the price of the coin that we're dealing
with
so now what we want to do we're done
with add view we're going to go back to
our home view and we're going to
manipulate this a little bit
okay so the way that we're going to work
with this data
is we're going to do the following we're
going to say double bitcoin
is equal to 0.0 do the same for ethereum
and for tether
then we're going to override our init
states
and what we're going to do is we're
going to say
get values
and then we're going to have get values
be asynchronous
and the reason for this you can't do
asynchronous methods with an init state
so we're going to create a simple method
that's called add a net state
to go and grab the newest values for
each of these coins
and we're going to say um
bitcoin
is equal to get price
of bitcoin
this needs to be a weight and we're
gonna do the same thing
for ethereum
and for tether
then we're going to call set state just
to make sure those get set
okay okay so
what we're doing is when the page
initially loads we're going to go ahead
and call our api method and get the
current price for each of these three
coins that the user could potentially
show and then what we're going to do is
we're going to have another method
within our widget that's going to be
called
get value but this one's going to have
parameters it's going to have
a id and it's going to have a double of
type
amount
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to say
if id is equal to
bitcoin
return um
bitcoin times amount
else if id is equal to
ethereum return ethereum
times amount and otherwise it must be
tether
so return tether times amount
okay so what we're doing here is we're
going to be calling this
from within our individual rows
to get the current price and so we're
going to say okay get the current price
of bitcoin
and multiply it by whatever amount that
you're passing me that the user owns of
that
and so we're going to say pass the coin
you're looking at
and we're going to check and see which
one it is and then we're going to
multiply
the current price of that coin by the
amount of that coin that the user owns
so utilizing this method we're going to
go down here
into our stream builder go into our list
view
and for amount owned we are
now going to say um
get value
oh my goodness i'm having trouble here
it's gonna be document.id
and then the second variable
is the amount of that coin
okay
we want to put a dollar sign in front of
it
and we want to say dot to string
or let's do two fixed or that's what it
is to string as fixed
and let's go to two decimal places
so this will make sure that if our
number that we get back our double has
like
two plus like it could have like five
decimal places we want to make sure we
only show two so it looks like a
legitimate number
and keep in mind that this is in u.s
dollars if you'd like to use a different
currency
you can look at the api documentation
you can figure out which one is
represented
is represents your country so for
example we have the euro
i believe canada is in here cad
it has pretty much every common
well-known
currency um on here that it can compare
to
okay so let's go ahead and test this out
and make sure that it
is giving us the proper price
and so we're going to run this and while
we're running it we're going to go ahead
and check out firestore really quick
give it a refresh
and let's see roughly what we think it
should equal
so we have and eight tether coins let's
see
tether to dollar
okay one tether is about one dollar so
we should see
about 108 for tether and for bitcoin we
have okay let's see
one bitcoin price
and we should see 10
800 to 10 900 somewhere in there for
bitcoin
let's pull up in our emulator
let's log in
awesome perfect not exact well
actually what do i know i um i was given
a rough estimate but it looks like
that's
correct like that's the amount that we
want to have so the last thing we need
to do is let's go ahead and give these
some styling
and then maybe we can even add in like a
x icon and if they hit it then we just
sell
everything we just clear out that coin
just so you can get familiar with how to
delete
things from a document okay
and going over really quickly when it
comes to deleting if you want to allow
the user to delete up to a certain
amount like i just want to sell
half of my bitcoin what you're going to
do is you're going to do something
similar
to the transaction that we did with
adding coins but instead of
adding onto you will subtract the amount
that you want to do from that
coin so it's a very similar method for
this example
just to wrap it up and make it concise
we're going to just say delete all
so let's manipulate this this container
here
so the first thing we can do is we can
give it some decoration
give it a box decoration
we do border radius
dot circular let's do 15
we can do so unique coloring so we can
say color
is equal to colors.blue
um we can do let's do some text styling
here
let's say text style color
as we go to colors.white
and let me go here
and again i'm going to be putting all of
this code
i'll be putting all this code online and
so if you have any questions
or wanna or you wanna slow it down a
little bit and
get a better feel for it you can always
go back and check out that code
okay
oh i'm sorry i forgot the key part of
styling
is the style tag i was wondering why i
was getting a little error there
okay that's good
um we're gonna wrap this whole thing
so container we've given it a width
have we we have not given it a width
oh we have no we haven't okay sorry for
the back and forth
let's give it a width
let's give it a height
give it a hot reload
i'm sorry i meant restart hot restart
okay looks good now we need some padding
um let's do container
return padding
childish container
and padding
the edge insets dot vertical
only top
five
looks good um
i'm still slightly confused as to why
this isn't working the way i want it to
the sizing isn't how i want it um
let's do this instead let's do left
15 right
15.
okay
that looks good that looks good to me
okay let's go ahead and add that button
add that button button i'm sorry
my mouth is getting a little dry
okay let's go ahead and add that button
and what i'm going to do to create a
little bit more room
i'm going to delete this i think it's
pretty self-explanatory when you see
the dollar sign and i don't think we
need to include
name so we're trying to do is we're just
trying to free up a little bit more
space to
include that button and we're gonna have
an icon here
icons dot close maybe
i'm not 100 sure what that icon looks
like
and then we're going to say color colors
dot red
[Applause]
and actually now that i think about it
we need an icon button
okay on pressed
let's just print something so we can
test it
okay um
i'm going to say space between
just make it a little bit cleaner
that looks good we want some spacing on
the left of those coins and we on it
up the font size so first font size
um let's say 18.
and add in that padding on the left so
the way we can do this
is we can just put a size box
of type width 5.0
just the left of that first item
reload it look at it looks good to me
so we've got that padding on the left
the x's will always be on the right
let's see if that was printing or not
output
there we go debug console that was what
i was looking for
let's try this again okay
that's good so now we can move on to our
remove method
so let's go back to our flutter fire
let's create a future method
type bool we'll call it remove
and we'll pass in an id
and we're going to say remove coin
actually
so we're first going to do is we want to
get the user's uid
so we've already done this up above
get the current uid of the user
then what we're going to do is we're
going to say firebase firestore
dot instance dot collection
users dot
doc uid
dot collection and we're gonna say once
again
um coins
dot doc id
and then we're going to say dot delete
what this will do is it will delete that
document from our list
okay so now all we have to do is we need
to reference it oh
i'm sorry and
return true now we have to do
is go back to our home view within our
icon button
we can say async
and then we're just going to say await
or we call it remove coin and
we want to specify the coin we want to
remove which is going to be
document.data
actually not even.data document.id
and then we need to import our flutter
fire into this page into this
dart file okay
we're gonna do a hard restart and we're
gonna try this on our
tether coin
okay it's gone from our list but let's
double check and make sure it truly
removed it
and it looks like it did now let's try
it with bitcoin
let's go back to firebase and it removed
bitcoin as well
awesome let's go ahead and just add in
perfect okay
so we've successfully completed our
crypto wallet
clearly there's always a lot of other
things that you can do with this
um if you'd like to challenge yourself a
little bit more i would suggest
doing the following things one
incorporate
some more advanced business logic
state management into the app two
establish some classes and work on api
usage and improving how you utilize
responses
and three work on the styling you can
never
learn too much when it comes to flutter
styling i hope that this is a good app
to
break you in and get you comfortable
working with firestore
firebase authentication and basic api
usage
it's really not as hard as some people
make it out to be i hope that you felt
the same way doing this tutorial with me
once again i'd like to thank free code
camp for giving the opportunity to
teach you guys and show you guys how to
utilize firebase in your flutter
application
and as always i'll catch you guys next
time thanks for joining me